foreign
[Music]
70 years after Queen Elizabeth was
crowned head of the British Monarchy her
son King Charles is prepping for his own
big day and a source close to the royal
family tells ET he wants his son Prince
Harry by his side it is his son after
all and the King really does want a
Reconciliation in the long term
Charles's coronation is May 6th and the
big question is whether Harry and his
wife Meghan Markle will get an invite
our Royal Source says it's a pivotal
moment in his life he loves both his
sons and wants Prince Harry there I
think he wants to be magnanimous I think
he wants to take a leaf out of the late
Queen's book and I think he ultimately
wants to to heal the rift and he wants
his son at his coronation this comes
following the current tension between
the sussexes and the royal family due to
the Duke's remarks in their Netflix
stock Harry and Megan his Memoir spare
and recent TV interviews it was
terrifying to have my brother Scream and
Shout at me and my father say things
that just simply weren't true and my
grandmother you know quietly sit there
and sort of Take It All In I vividly
remember that thought flashing through
my mind
and I remember waiting patiently for
Paul to confirm that indeed mummy was
all right
and I remember him not doing that she
was the villain
she was the third person in the marriage
she needed to rehabilitate Her Image you
and your brother both directly asked
your dad not to marry Camilla yes but
despite it all the king wants to move
forward the source close to the family
says he wants to mend the relationship
within the family quote Megan and Harry
will be invited it would look terrible
if they were not however Prince Harry
will have no official role as he's no
longer a working member of the family
but the run-up to the coronation to be
overshadowed by these Headlines by Harry
and Megan in this Royal rival Court over
in America is problematic so really a
Reconciliation is going to be in the
best interest of the firm whether that's
a real and meaningful and long-lasting
Reconciliation well that's the million
dollar question can that actually happen
so what's Harry's role if he's involved
well the source explains it'll be
similar to his role at the Queen's
funeral where he took part as a member
of the family but not as a senior a
working member in past coronations
traditionally all the Royal Dukes would
swear allegiance to the new king at this
coronation it is expected that only
Prince William will do so
[Music]